a hair-raising attempted robbery in
south africa is caught on camera
this video from last month shows an
armored car crew coming under gunfire in
broad
daylight you can see the bullets
ricochet off the windows leaving
spiderweb cracks behind
as deborah powder reports this morning
while crimes like this seem brazen they
are becoming a common occurrence
in south africa every time security
officer leo prince luer gets behind the
wheel
he is taking his life into his hands on
this particular day new recruit
lloyd into benny is in the passenger
seat he'd only been on the job for four
days
it was a true baptism of fire
there's nothing that really can
you know prepare you 100 for for a
situation like that
um the first time i knew they were there
was when the when the gunshots went off
you know instinct kicks in pretty much
instinct
and nerves of steel on the dash cam
video prince lure is seen using his
vehicle as a weapon
to fend off a barrage of shots as he
calmly weaves through a steady stream of
traffic
a camera mounted on the outside of the
armored truck
gives an idea of just what he was up
against
prince lua has since gone to ground
after receiving multiple death
rates cash and transit heists have
become a lucrative business
for criminal syndicates in south africa
regularly
executed with military precision dion
courtier runs a training company for
security officers
and says they are dealing with around
five to six hits a week across
south africa and attackers are seldom
caught
i want to call it policing with
restricted resources and also corruption
in police
so that ends up being a terrible mixture
for us
but a very good mixture for criminals
you know creating
even for them it's a high gain low risk
business
as this toxic mixture of corruption and
ineffective law enforcement
means syndicates are raking in millions
in both
hard cash and valuable goods but with
prince lewis courage under fire
for once the syndicates did not get the
upper hand
cash and transit heists are growing
increasingly brazen
often taking place in broad daylight on
roads like this one
and since lockdown regulations were
eased in south africa
the number of incidents has risen
sharply for cbs this morning saturday
debra patter johannesburg
sounds like they need some additional
security measures
his reaction was incredible unbelievable
i mean so fast and just moved
unbelievable